and that is where you have this
existential crisis you know and then is
there more to life than the you can you
can have a husband I mean islamically if
you marry a a a husband inah he can
maybe do that for you at home uh but
yeah there's a Halal option there you
know there's nothing wrong with that so
no gay no lesbian yeah we we we believe
the same that we believe it's a sin but
we don't jge like we don't come 100%
it's a sin it's a sin we don't but we
don't condemn them we don't condemn them
to hell we don't see like we believe a a
person can be a Muslim and have gay
inclinations but but let me let me tell
you how what I would say is maybe
there's a misunderstanding no sin takes
you out the fold of being a Muslim so if
you go drink alcohol today oh yeah can
we go sin
now I'm was having such a good
conversation so so
so earrings have a purpose you probably
had it matching with something your
dress or maybe your shoes my dress
you're dressed there you go so you woke
up today and thought you know what I'm
going to dress up and I'm going to make
sure my earrings are matching my wife my
wife after I pick for her yes so
basically the argument is the following
your earrings are a mere object and they
have a purpose they have a design and
they have a designer You Are a Human
Being you have eyes you can hear you've
got a heart you've got lungs you breathe
so side so so the point is this what's
your purpose like the question we need
to ask is why are we here like who put
you here do you ever think to yourself
why am I here where am I going I have no
purpose you have to but that is a
purpose to say I don't have a purpose is
a purpose I need to try and find my good
so why will say this sister yeah look I
did this 11 years ago I became a Muslim
even though I know I look Muslim uh 11
years ago so I looked in 13 years ago I
used to go clubing partying in this
strip every
weekend yes but the point came in my
life where I was like this just boring
yeah it just gets boring like every time
like obviously I didn't drink I was not
into alcohol because of health reasons
but clubbing partying all this kind of
stuff it came to a point where I was
like is there more to life and that is
where you have this existential crisis
you know and then is there more to life
than this
the to the male strippers yeah okay you
can you can have a husband I me
islamically if you marry a a a husband
inah he can maybe do that for you at
home uh but
yeah there's a Halal option there you
know there's nothing wrong with that so
yeah so I came to the point where I was
like hold on a second there must be a
greater purpose so then I knew God
exists you believe in God yeah I said
there must be a reason he put me here
because it's impossible that a Creator
exists but he's a purposeless God
because everything that everyone that's
created something or designed something
your jacket your bag your shoes trainers
this mik to that camera they did it for
a reason they found a need for it they
made a purpose and they designed it what
about the one that created us you are
far in complex in design your eyesight
your eye vision your eye is far complex
than any camera on this Earth so it
points to a higher being that wants
goodness for you we believe that there's
a Hereafter that there's hell in heaven
and you'll be judged and God just wants
you to have a relationship with him
that's our main purpose we don't believe
God is a man we don't believe he's a
woman we believe there is nothing like
him so what do you believe do you
believe there's of Jesus in God like the
Catholic yes so so we are very close to
the Christian so Allah in the Quran
tells us we have a whole chapter called
Mary you know the mother of Jesus maram
yes there's a whole chapter on her
mother because we believe she's one of
the most holiest woman that was sent to
Earth so we believe that Jesus was a
prophet he was sent by God Almighty to
tell the people to worship God Alone
yeah we don't believe he's God
Christians believe he's God they deify
him but you will accept like let me put
it like this would you ever believe God
is a man like
me good this is what we call in Islam
called the fitra what that means is we
as Muslims believe every person is born
a Muslim meaning you have the
inclination by when I asked you and said
Do you believe God is a man you said no
that's called the F your programming the
way God has programmed you you can
distinguish what is God and who God is
Not So you believe that God is a Muslim
no we believe we are Muslims and Muslims
are the ones that submit their will to
God so when you submit your will to God
I'm like you're a Muslim do you get it
obviously you have to believe in Allah
and the Quran and the prophet that's a
different discussion but for you to
accept that God is one he has no
Partners he's not a male or female and
there is nothing like him is a good step
towards being a Muslim in that sense you
get it in the proper way yeah cuz my
Nana is a Christian and she goes to
church every week okay um she's a strong
Irish Christian okay um so no gays no
lesbians yeah we we we believe the same
that we believe it's a sin but we don't
jge like we don't come 100% it's a sin
it's a sin we don't but we don't condemn
them we don't condemn to hell we don't
say like we believe a a person can be a
Muslim and have gay
inclinations but let me let me tell you
how to not become a Muslim it means you
don't believe or reject God or associate
partner him look for example there there
could be a man who's in adulterer he
just sleeps around with girls now is
that a sin yes okay but does that mean
he cannot be a Christian or a Muslim we
say no you are a sinner you are still a
Muslim but you need to stop the sin yeah
okay so same as a gay person homosexual
we believe that it's a major sin however
it does not take you out the fold unless
you say being homosexual is it's God
said it's okay then you then you're in
trouble but I feel like if he was to say
this about 5 years ago then it would be
completely exactly but do you see this
is why but nowadays it's like but I
still feel like it's wrong no no same no
I believe it is a wrong it is a major
sin it's just that it's just that we
just say that they can still be a Muslim
but they should repent from that and try
to go back to it but it feels like
you're going back on your own religion
to suit other people okay so what I
would say is maybe there's a
misunderstanding no sin takes you out
the fold of being a Muslim so if you go
drink alcohol today oh yeah can we go
sin
now I'm almost having such a good
conversation yeah so so so yeah just I
obviously I don't want to hold you guys
you guys we want to go somewhere but no
sin takes you out the fold of Islam
unless you associate Partners to God all
right that's the only thing so we are
all sinners I'm a sinner I'm not an
angel
you know and God doesn't want us to be
Angels 100% yeah if you sin repent s
with a man marry him you'd marry a man
no no no you no sorry I thought you
meant youor you with a man no no that's
that's that's not that's that's a major
sin yeah that's a that's a major sin
that's all I want to say thank you sorry
to keep you You' been very patient with
me thank you if you have any questions
I'm here my name is Ali da on YouTube I
have YouTube videos my name is Ali dawa
I'm Live on YouTube but also if you want
to watch my videos this will be out on
my YouTube channel my name is Ali da if
you want to add it it's up to you okay
yes thank you sister sorry if I um
offended no yes yes thank you so much
and thank you okay guys as you can see
span Allah you know what's one one
pattern that I'm seeing quite
interestingly is there's people who have
good intentions and when they want
goodness but they are they are their
friends are pulling them away I've seen
this many times in Leicester Square
there are people ah ah not again mate
trans for me okay so so guys yeah one
thing that I've noticed even happened
yesterday guys where the the guy is
interested in knowing about Islam
knowing about God but their friends are
dragging them away like even you saw
with this uh this lady this sister she's
interested she wants to know about her
friend is that no let's go sing and we
did this Etc this is why it's so
important to have good friends very
important to have good friends so alhamd
that's what we're doing guys giv up okay